Traductor: Rafa Peris
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Qué tienen en común estos animales?
Más de lo que podrían pensar.
Junto con más de 5000 otras especies,
son mamíferos,
o miembros de la categoría "mammalia".
Todos los mamíferos son vertebrados,
es decir, tienen una espina dorsal.
Pero los mamíferos se distinguen
de otros vertebrados
por una serie de rasgos compartidos.
Eso incluye: sangre caliente,
pelo corporal o pelaje,
la capacidad de respirar usando pulmones
y nutrir a sus crías con leche.
Pero a pesar de estas similitudes,
estas criaturas también tienen
muchas diferencias biológicas
y una de las más notables
es cómo dan a luz.
Comencemos con los más comunes,
los mamíferos placentarios.
Este grupo incluye a los humanos,
los gatos,
los perros,
las jirafas,
e incluso a la ballena azul,
el animal más grande de la Tierra.
Su placenta, un sólido disco
de tejido rico en sangre,
se adhiere a la pared del útero
y da soporte al embrión en desarrollo
La placenta es lo que mantiene vivo
el ternero durante el embarazo.
Conectado directamente al suministro
de sangre de la madre,
introduce los nutrientes y el oxígeno
directamente en el cuerpo de la cría
a través del cordón umbilical,
y también exporta sus residuos.
Los mamíferos placentarios pueden pasar
mucho más tiempo en el útero
que otros mamíferos.
Las crías de ballena azul, por ejemplo,
pasan casi un año completo
dentro de su madre.
La placenta mantiene a la cría viva
hasta su nacimiento,
cuando el cordón umbilical se rompe
y los propios sistemas
del recién nacido: respiratorio,
circulatorio
y de eliminación de desechos
se hacen cargo.
Midiendo alrededor de 7 metros,
una cría recién nacida
es capaz ya de nadar.
Pasará los próximos seis meses
bebiendo 225 litros de leche grasa
y espesa de su madre, al día.
Mientras tanto, en Australia,
puedes encontrar un segundo
tipo de mamífero:
los marsupiales.
Los bebés marsupiales son tan pequeños
y delicados cuando nacen
que deben continuar desarrollándose
en la bolsa de la madre.
Por ejemplo el quoll, uno de los
marsupiales más pequeños del mundo,
pesa solo 18 miligramos al nacer,
el equivalente a unos 30 granos de azúcar.
El canguro, otro marsupial,
da a luz a un solo bebé del tamaño
de una gominola por vez.
El bebé se arrastra por el centro
de las tres vaginas de la madre,
luego debe subir hasta la bolsa,
donde pasa los próximos
6 a 11 meses en lactancia.
Incluso después de que el bebé canguro
deje este cálido refugio,
volverá para succionar leche.
A veces, ella es solo
uno de los tres bebés
que su madre está cuidando.
Una canguro hembra a menudo
puede soportar simultáneamente
a uno dentro de su útero
y a otro en su bolsa.
En condiciones desfavorables,
los canguros hembra pueden
suspender sus embarazos.
Cuando eso sucede, ella es capaz de
producir dos clases diferentes de leche,
una para su recién nacido,
y una para su cría más mayor.
La palabra "mammalia"
significa "de la mama",
que es un nombre poco apropiado porque
aunque los canguros producen leche
de los pezones que hay en las bolsas,
en realidad no tienen mamas.
Tampoco tienen los Monotremas,
el tercer y posiblemente
más extraño ejemplo
de nacimiento mamífero.
Hubo una vez cientos
de especies de monotremas,
pero solo quedan cinco:
cuatro especies de Equidnas
y el ornitorrinco.
El nombre monotrema significa "un agujero"
refiriéndose al único orificio
que usan para la reproducción,
la excreción
y la puesta de huevos.
Como los pájaros,
los reptiles,
los peces,
los dinosaurios
y otros,
estas especies ponen huevos
en lugar de dar a luz a crías vivas.
Sus huevos son de cáscara blanda,
y cuando sus bebés eclosionan,
toman la leche de los poros
del cuerpo de su madre
hasta que sean lo suficientemente grandes
para alimentarse por ellos mismos.
A pesar de poner huevos
y otras adaptaciones
que no asociamos a los mamíferos,
como las patas palmeadas del ornitorrinco,
el pico,
y los venenosos espolones
que el macho tiene en sus patas,
son, de hecho, mamíferos.
Esto se debe a que comparten
las características definitorias
de los mamíferos
y están evolutivamente
vinculados al resto de la clase.
Ya sea placentaria,
marsupial,
o monotrema,
cada una de estas criaturas
y sus métodos únicos de parto,
por muy bizarros que parezcan,
han tenido éxito durante muchos
milenios en traer nueva vida
y diversidad al reino de los mamíferos.